it's been over 24 hours since Donald
Trump became the president-elect of the
United States and on Thursday he wife
Melania will meet with Barack and
Michelle Obama at the White House we've
learned that women can be anything
except for president already the social
commentary is flying in and NBC has
opted to pull a trump inspired episode
of Law & Order SVU of course celebrities
still have a lot to say about the
results of the election - from those who
supported Trump including Kirstie Alley
and Stephen Baldwin if you agree or not
the cool thing to do is really give mr.
Trump the opportunity to those who
didn't like Rosie O'Donnell george RR
martin and Chelsea Handler I guess the
message that I want to like spread out
to other women is is exactly what you're
saying is not to give up sorry I hate
crying on camera but is not to give up
because this is so important well there
are tears there also seems to be a
strong message of hope out there from
Hillary supporters my job is to be
hopeful and to make everybody feel good
and I am gonna keep doing that for as
long as I can John Legend shared this
sweet family photo asking for love and
empathy Aaron Sorkin penned an emotional
letter to his daughters in Vanity Fair
telling them to fight for what they
believe in and a Jennifer Lawrence wrote
an essay for broadly encouraging others
to educate themselves on the issues that
matter to them moving forward Amy
Schumer vowed to stay in the USA despite
it joking she would leave and Katy Perry
even revealed her parents voted for
Trump but quote we will all still be
sitting at the same table for
Thanksgiving and in this is the moment
we need to remember that we all love our
parents and we all love our children
you